[Music]
yes of optics committed October wifack
leasing and holdigaz commission estimates
bettina exit from the ministry supports
two commissions inietsa week it
was said in congress and in the penalty shootout
[Music]
I pointed out that the commission was doing
its analysis of the plans  budgets in
a precise and objective way, keeping in
mind the common interest of the euro zone of
all our fellow citizens,
it is also for this reason that
we are so keen on the importance
of a constructive dialogue between the
European Commission and the
Member States  on the fact that the commission
totally respects the
democratic national hard discount choices
or programs in all who play frost
design by black69 in uniform everywhere
even if it means destabilizing my golf on the
program of the Olympics
[Music]